ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
If you've seen previous GCP
Essentials videos,
you should now
have a good sense of
what GCP has to offer.
It's time to get your feet
wet and your hands dirty.
And if you haven't, then
consider checking out
the series playlist.
In this video, we'll
talk about all the ways
you can experience GCP with
hands-on code labs, tutorials,
online courses, and solutions,
all at little or no cost.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we talk about
hands-on resources,
let me remind you about
the Google Cloud home
page at cloud.google.com.
It all starts there.
Product documentation
lives there, for instance.
And chances are you will
spend some quality time there
as you learn and research
specific products and APIs.
Make sure you check out the
Documentation Quick Start.
These 30-minute tutorials offer
a step-by-step walk-through
of some basic tasks, such
as creating a Linux VM,
storing a file and sharing it,
deploying a Docker container
image, running a label
detection on a photograph,
or deploying an
application on App Engine.
You can also find interactive
tutorials embedded right
into the console.
Select one of the dozen
or so product tutorials
and let the tutorial
guide you step-by-step
through the console
user interface.
If you're looking for
self-based hands-on experience,
we have a lot in store for you.
First, Google code labs are
available at g.co/codelabs,
and they have a very
rich cloud section.
There are more
than 200 free labs,
covering the vast
majority of GCP products.
You can sort by category,
duration, and publish dates.
Each lab should only
cost you $1 or $2,
which can be covered by the
$300 free trial credits.
But do make sure to follow the
CodeLab's clean-up instructions
to properly delete all
resources that can incur costs.
Second, there is Qwiklabs.
If you're planning
for a certification
or would like to take a series
of related hands-on labs,
also known as
Quests, then Qwiklabs
offers you a
personalized platform
to track your progress.
Simply sign up for a free
account, buy some credits,
and start a quest.
Each lab comes with a
real, but temporary, GCP
account and a project ID
available for the duration
of the lab.
Note, also, that Qwiklabs
is the hands-on tool
that Coursera uses to deliver
its courses and specialization.
Now, getting your hands
on individual products
and understanding the scope
and features is great,
but understanding how different
products actually work together
is also very useful.
And this is where
Solutions come into play.
These detailed,
technical articles
often come with
source code and are
grouped into categories, such
as modernize infrastructure,
migrate workloads, hybrid
cloud, HPC, big data analytics,
machine learning, IoT,
continuous delivery,
serverless API
management, et cetera.
You can also browse by
industry or vertical solutions,
such as retail, energy,
financial services, gaming,
and others.
These solutions are all based
on customer best practices
and common use cases.
And they come with detailed
descriptions and code
to make sure you can
learn from others
and jump-start your
GCP developments.
As you can see, there's
plenty of hands-on material
that is available
and waiting for you.
So what are you waiting for?
Grab a tutorial, take a
code lab, study a solution,
and get those hands dirty.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to
more GCP Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]